foreign
building collapsed hours after the
massive earthquake hit
it struck Before Dawn as most people
were still asleep in bed the moment was
captured on a Shop's CCTV camera as it
shook for almost 90 seconds
[Applause]
as first light broke across Southern
turkey the sheer scale of the damage
became evident
the death toll started to rise rapidly
and the coming hours will be an urgent
rush to find survivors under the rubble
the Turkish government has quickly
assessed that um that in order to rescue
as many people as possible in the short
use our frame uh with a short window
um International assistance is necessary
to be able to help as many people as
possible and as quickly as possible
the earthquake was powerful and shallow
only six miles beneath the surface
and it was felt around the Middle East
some of the worst reports of Devastation
of coming out of Northwest Syria where
many of the buildings are already
damaged from 12 Years of Civil War and
there are hundreds of thousands of
refugees
today after the earthquake we started to
receive many cases hundreds of
casualties we have information that
hundreds of patients are still under the
breasts the situation is too bad we need
Argent help
we felt the Quake it was very strong so
I ran out with my wife and children we
ran directly towards the entrance of the
house as we reached the entrance of the
building it totally collapsed upon us
thank you
turkey has declared a state of emergency
and already requested international
support Aid will start arriving from
around the world but getting into
rebel-held parts of Syria will be a
challenge in itself
major aftershocks have followed the
initial earthquake including one
recorded at 6.7 magnitude
the next few hours a circle to revealing
more tragedy as the rescue effort gets
underway
ouster bunker Sky News